why does everyone hate Nikki Haley so
much does everyone hate it seems like
every loves oh my God the the corporate
press loves Nicki Haley you mean Nika
Haley yeah is that her real name
Nik he just wanted to say that other N
word found a way to sneak it in this
mother he almost made me
say yeah yeah okay go with a normal Rond
Haley she calls me Vic so she [__] it
up on purpose I I think I think that
it's almost I I don't know that she
thinks of it as doing it on purpose but
it's almost native and hardwired to who
she is that it's exactly how does she
know what [__] cast you are dude does
she know you're a [__] B the thing is
it doesn't it doesn't make it for her
there's one there's one currency that
matters which is which is power personal
power and do whatever she think she is
just insane lust for power insane lust
for power and she is tied to the
corporate interests is that what the
would greatest criticism is I would say
that I would say it's not specific
spefic to her right could it could apply
to Dick Cheney you could apply to anyone
of a certain breed of Republican yeah or
anyone in the neoliberal kind of fashion
of democrat too over the last 25
years is whatever it takes to accumulate
an added ounce of money and power is
what we're going to do use an ideology
as a vector to do it to project American
power which actually is a philosophy
that creates American weakness in the
name of creating an illusion of power
and we're going to fight Foreign Wars
and we're create a domestic surveillance
State as a consequence and you could put
a d at the end of it or you could put an
r at the end of it the same philosophy
hiding on the front and that's what she
represents and so I think what's going
on in the Republican party right now is
there's an ideological fissure about
what this party is I mean what does it
mean to be Republican it's kind of a
meaningless term really it it's Biden
bad is the closest thing that the
Republican part has had to an agenda in
the last you know years Biden bad Trump
goody B bad win are good our team good
what do we what do we stand for MH and
so I think we should stand for the two
basic ideas I said at the beginning the
people we El to run the government
should run the government they they ow
moral duty to the citizens of this
nation not another one simple two simple
ideas but I think there's an alternative
view that says it's the job of the US to
be the global hamon that's the police
Global police state keeper and in order
to do that we have to have a federal
police state at home that
requires under the table violations of
your constitutional rights and if that
means tying your social media accounts
to government issued ID as a mandate to
use the internet which is a policy she's
advocated for that's what it takes and
so the the post 911 Dick Cheney George
Bush Patriot Act Iraq war fuming
Republicans have created a modern Avatar
it's called Nicki Haley right and
they're trying to reclaim this thing
known as the Republican party and then
there's an alternative Vision that says
it's what I would call kind of a
Libertarian nationalist Vision I think
I'm the only person to use that term but
that's how it describe my view of the
world to say that the the way of the
future is one of guaranteeing at all
costs our constitutionally enshrined
freedoms and to take care of the
citizens of this country so n represents
traditional conservative I wouldn't even
call it conservative because
conservative is is Let's find let's find
the right word the machine the FY word
for this would be neoconservative is she
deep State she's a product of the deep
State she's product of deep Biden is
also product of I would say of the okay
that's a great way to look at it because
it feels as if for the average person
that Biden is being run right he is
being run he's being run that's what the
average person but we don't know what
really that means who runs him do you
have names of people who run him it's so
comes back to this man it's the machine
you could what's the machine you could
pick your Susan Rice's or the Hillary
clintons or the Barack Obamas but it
doesn't matter because currently do we
know who's doing it's like the San
Antonio Spurs right it doesn't matter
papic runs that but who's the papovich
yeah so so I think that I think imagine
imagine if papovich steps out in the
middle of a game and the whole thing
just keeps running as its own machine
Becky Hammond steps in I know the
coaching I don't even know if she's not
there anymore but what I'm saying it
doesn't matter who it is and the Machine
still runs I'm aware it is it is here's
how here's how it works here's how it
works there go and this is not to go I
want to catch you I don't think you're
using I'm genuinely trying to understand
a phrase that I feel like I've used
Without Really knowing at a certain
point the bureaucracy becomes its own
creation that's what it is so if you
want to take for example the FBI can I
say one thing about this and how it
helps me understand so in Hollywood
before I did really anything in
entertainment and I was on the outside
of it I thought that there was these
like organized meetings uh amongst
people in Hollywood they're like here's
the agenda we're going to push trans
we're going to push gay
we're what I learned doubt is that it's
people that are trying to keep their job
yeah and by trying to keep their job
they're doing the things that they
believe will be rewarded or very least
they won't be punished yes so is this
what you mean by so so there's a version
of that um I mean I think that a lot of
what most people refer to as conspiracy
theories the ones that certainly are
true are really just an amalgam of
collective incentives that are hiding in
side that we think there's these
nefarious individuals that are holding
there is there is no smoke fil room
you're Miss if if you're wor if you're
fixated on where's the smoke filed room
you're missing the point right right and
so I think that like you know this idea
of you know that you're not supposed to
utter uh you know the great replacement
Theory or whatever this idea that
there's an intentional plot to supplant
the native white stock of the US for a
bunch of people crossing the southern
border to permanently secure electoral
outcomes to the contrary that's
conspiracy theory but if you take great
replacement Theory out of it you take
the idea of somebody concocting this in
a smoke filed room out of it and then
you just look at the last 20 years of
policy much of one of the two political
parties in the US as recently as about a
decade ago said well immigration legal
or not is going to be a key to securing
lasting electoral majorities and so
that's why we should tend to favor this
including even in the context of that
was you can't even remember the context
was convincing a kind of Bernie esque
minority view that was sort of skeptical
of competition for domestic workers to
sort of it was a carrot to say no no no
I know that this might like in the short
run run against some of the things you
stand for but think about what it could
open up in the long run if we have
lasting electoral majorities so it was
Earnest as a persuasion mechanism that
today if
uttering uttered by people on the
so-called other side becomes a
conspiracy theory when it's nothing more
than just a statement of incentiv hiding
in plain sight so it goes with the
bureaucracy and I want to say a word
about the bureaucracy I don't love the
word deep state only because it implies
that it's limited to the government what
I call it people don't like it when I
say this and say they say it doesn't
resonate with people but the word that I
use is it's the managerial class is
Jamie Diamond part of the managerial
class I think the people uh two to three
layers below Jamie Diamond absolutely
are and I think in some sense Jamie
Diamond is is is on it so there's three
classes of people of I talk about this
my first book woke in a little bit I
mean you got the creators right the
actual you could could be a professor at
a university as opposed to the associate
dean of God knows what could be the
entrepreneur proprietor who started the
company as opposed to the vice president
of Human Resources could be the elected
president of the United States versus
you know the class that sits underneath
them you got the creators you've got the
constituents C customers
shareholders
voters and then you've got the
managerial class who are the higher
middle management bureaucracy designed
to administer that which the creators
have created with the intention of
serving the constituents but to make it
scalable like that's that's the basic
premise of it in a corporate context or
not and I think we live in a moment
right now where the balance of power
between those three categories has
vastly shifted
towards the managerial class the class
as we could call it the permanent the
permanent bureaucracy or what we call in
government the permanent State I think
it's true in every sphere of our lives
right now I think it's true in Corporate
America I think it's true in
universities but it so happens and I do
think it's the mother of all
bureaucracies it is absolutely true in
the government that the people who we
elect have almost nothing to do with
what actually impacts most people's
everyday lives compared to the permanent
machine that sits under it and is
fundamentally agnostic to the political
party who's on top as long as they're
going to keep the party going
so Joe bid's one version of that Nikki
H's another version of that either which
is a safe Choice deep state is
essentially just bureaucracy and your
mission as president would have been to
eliminate dismantle 7% a jack a
jackhammer like a chainsaw and I'm just
trying to help people who might be like
oh this guy wants to abolish the
Department of Education what the [__] is
that you're just trying to eliminate the
bureaucracy from the Department of
Education eliminate the bureaucracy from
so many of the FBI all the bureaucrat
the bureaucracy
itself is causing what is causing a
separation between what the constituents
want and what the executive the
dissipation of accountability is what
disappears so they know the managerial
yeah folks no longer have accountability
to their constituents and that is
because there is this they don't even
have constituents that's the thing they
don't even have constituents so I'll
give it to you in a corporate context so
we can depoliticize it then we can bring
it back to politics like in Corporate
America right now and this is where I
spent my career shortly before running
for president
is you have something that happened
basically in original OG capitalism you
have the proprietor who's also the owner
who's also the CEO and the operator then
it all comes down to a question of scale
so the question is oh we couldn't scale
that without hiring Professional
Management so that the owner can do
other things and create new things or or
whatever the owner wants to do and so he
hires the CEO and the CFO Etc and so
there was like in business school for I
don't know if you have back or doesn't
matter but if you go to business school
one of the things they'll teach you
about is the separation of owners ship
and control so that was like one of the
original sins kind of thing where the
owner is no longer the person who
exercises control and that creates what
they call a principal agent problem so
the principal is the owner the agent is
The Hired Hand and then like all of
modern corporate law and business Theory
and Securities Law is designed to
basically address that Gap so they have
these things called fiduciary duties
that the CEO will owe to the owner but
eventually they start behaving badly in
a way that just
flies run private jets at the owner's
expense and claim that it's a business
need and then that's where the private
Equity industry was actually born in the
1980s designed to sort of say okay well
we're going to retake ownership and
clean house and that was like where the
Henry kravis and the and the Steve
schwarzman kind of came from so that's
in the in the realm of capitalism then
something else happened in the last 20
years which is okay so we said the
shareholders are the ones who have
control but the managerial class having
not taken it over at the level of the
corporation went to the direction of the
shareholders themselves they started to
pretend to be the shareholders in the
guys of firms like Black Rock and State
Street or Vanguard or whatever that
Aggregate and I don't know how if these
words mean anything yes okay I mean
aggregate probably most of your money
directly or indirectly 401K accounts
Pension funds Etc to say that okay we
are the
shareholders but we're representing
other people's money and so we're going
to have you adopt policies that actually
are in our own interest not the
shareholders not not the actual
shareholders who the capital since we're
the shareholders cuz we're holding their
money we're holding the stock exactly so
you're using so let's say you're black
rock and let's say you're two retirees
you give your money over to Black Rock
black rock buys shares in I don't know
Apple sure actually that's a good
example to use because there was a
specific now they're using that leverage
on Apple to do what they want which
specifically on Apple and black rock
this is a real life story in 2022 voted
for racial Equity audits at Apple which
Apple initially said hell no to but they
said no no we're going to vote for it
and then back in the old school version
if the CEO was pushing that kind of
philosophy opy the shareholders would
say no you're the agent I'm the
principal and you have a fiduciary duty
to me but this it's always a cat and
mouse game but now it's gone to the
shareholders and they're like no no no
we are the shareholders and we're
telling you that you need to adop this
black Ro cuz today if you go to the
sec's website and see who are the
shareholders of Apple they're going to
be you know number one or two or three
on the list this is really interesting
and and so it's always this Captain
Mouse game where the managerial class is
always about getting one heads ups and
that's there's a whole private sector
version of this and two of my three
books are about this stuff and we could
go on for days about it but I use that
as analog CU I'm you talk about politics
people lose their mind there's something
similar going on and I think of even
greater Import in the government where
there's a cat- and- mouse game between
the elected representatives who say what
you will still have to go back to their
constituents every couple of years yes
every two four or six years depending on
Congress president or Senate yes and and
ask for permission to govern whereas
what these people says no no no how do
we drain as much of that power as
possible so that we're agnostic who are
these people the bureaucrats the
bureaucrats so these people absolutely
people who work for as from the electeds
as possible to make sure that we're
agnostic to who actually gets into power
in those seats in the first place so
they're neutering them intentionally
they're neutering them intentionally yes
depends how much detail you want to go
into but I all the detail this no this
is very important because I think a lot
of your ideas when explained in this way
are incredibly digestible that's the
problem is cable TV is 30 second hits or
or hold on hold on one second that's the
game though that is the game you know I
got to get good at that I've I've better
at you I mean we talked about uh you
know Bernie for example like I remember
when Bernie was going up against Trump
and there was this real there was this
real issue where I think like American
voters really wanted it to be Bernie
versus Trump and I think that they were
so disillusioned with that would have
been a good race that would have been a
useful race for the country actually I
I've like you know and I said it was
like ah the Democrats stole it from
Bernie with the whatever but here's the
reality that's the system that he was
operating Within and hasn't tried to
change so if the system can break you or
can sway using the what do they called
the um super super delicates or whatever
can that's the system that you and if
you're not breaking that system if
you're using that system that is you
become a productive exactly now bring a
jack cammera get the hell out drop the
mic 30 seconds a bite on M
mmbc this is another problem with the
bureaucracy you can even argue that is
impossible to describe an issue that is
this undated with [__] in 30 seconds
so that people don't even know where the
disconnect is between them and their
represent I'm sorry but I'm going to
interrupt I'm reading woke Inc I
actually do read you're reading it right
now I'm reading right now I'm listening
to the audio book actually to be honest
I don't I read the Audio I know that's
why I was more like inclined to do it
the the book and you're you are chapter
eight you are one of the most brilliant
people I've ever heard speak most people
are not you I'm an idiot I'm I'm
listening to your book and I'm not a lot
of this I'm just struggling to keep up
as you're even speaking now but I'm
reading woke in and you take this kind
of Wok conomics philosophy and you make
that The Boogeyman of corporate America
and I'm just an idiot who's listening to
you and I'm like well corporations and
you acknowledge it a little bit you're
like look corporations weren't they were
corrupt before but this is the problem
this woke economics is what's ruining
the country and it's like no the country
been [__] MH again I'm talking like an
idiot okay I think the issue if you had
made this about how bureaucracy ruins
government even outside of if you make
it woke ink and then you make the whole
boogey man you're framing it as wokeness
when the problem isn't just you heard me
talk a lot T about that in the last year
for a reason so one is just to bring you
context one thing I tell people about
Wok in is first of all I I I I probably
the three books I wrote most proud of
that one just because it took more of an
effort versus Le two you already got
your flow going but I agree with about
95% of what's in there that's the first
thing I will say you my I've written two
books since then and some of those I
evolved from certain of my micro views
but the other thing I will say is that
was just a product of my latest
experience I was a biotech CEO the story
I think I tell to start of the book yeah
and there's a state there's a demand
that I make a statement on behalf of BLM
I refuse to do it six months later I
write an opad in the Wall Street Journal
with a former law professor and then
multiple advisers for my company are
resigning what the hell is going on and
actually the the corporate America was
in a different and weird place in 2020
than it is today so I don't I don't mean
to be defensive but I don't believe I
said that oh this is really the the
threat to American future existence I'm
dumb people areum but it was but it was
what landed on my doorstep right and so
that was that was the thing that moved
me to write that book what I will say is
so so when I when I want people to
digest this this is interesting because
I think a lot of people have looked at
that book without even reading it as oh
he wants to run for president he's
seeing this woke wave going he's going
to write a book about how woke this is
destroying everything and he's going to
use that popularity run for president if
you actually read the book what you're
describing is you were put in a
situation where you could not do your
fiduciary responsibility to your
shareholders at Le what I felt was the
right what you felt because of this what
do you even call this this like social
pressure you can call there was yeah
there was social pressure and a
philosophy that was restricting your
ability to run your company to the best
and and to be clear in my case it was a
really mild example of it so I don't I
don't think I've ever overstated that in
the case of my company it was it was a
small shade compared to what was going
on in the rest of corporate America but
it opened my eyes that even in that
landing on my own doorstep and multiple
advisers to my company stepping aside
because of my own views that companies
should stay out of politics was an
eye-opening moment and I wrote a book
about the reflections that came out of
that at the time I titled woke in and
sent it to the publisher the main
criticism that I got including from
people in that world was that nobody had
heard this not enough people had heard
this word woke so this book is going to
fall flat this is back in 2020 when we
named it that's funny by the time it
came out a year and a half later then
the actual criticism was this is too
controversial and you're weaponizing the
word woke and then if that book were to
have come out today I'm sure the
criticism would be that this is Bal like
it's and you know what that time they
might actually be right see if I wrote
that book today and it comes out if
somebody else gives me a book that says
the same thing well King is coming out
today I'm like come on guys like this is
this is this is tired but it wasn't when
when it came out it was it was intended
to be read in the moment when it came
out is what I would say and you could
read it now for insight into how I think
about things but it was it was a product
of my own experiences and a product of
where I think we were in a particularly
weird place in our country we've the the
fight has moved on and one of the titles
one of the chapter titles in Wok Kink
was the rise of the managerial class
that's one chapter we blew that out into
a full
third book I wrote a second book called
nation of victims and then the third one
is called capitalist punishment which is
all about actually it's more specific to
sort of ESG and capital markets but goes
into this deeper issue of the managerial
class there's this author called I think
I don't know if he's on the left or and
the writer Some Kind too but Michael
Lind wrote a book recently and he was in
the school of thought of this guy um You
probably a century ago
Burnham Burnham James Burnham who talked
about this almost like back in the 30s
where this has been a phenomenon that's
existed for a long time and what it
actually gets to is this is as as
esoteric as it might sound what we're
talking about this what the American
Revolution was actually fought about see
see the American Revolution was fought
over the idea with the part I left out
about the Deep state is the people who
are believing that they need to drain
the lifeblood out of the
politicians the the most Sinister part
of it is they believe they're doing it
not even for their own good but for the
good of humanity and for
they believe that the elected represent
in exactly it is it is a noble lie that
has to be told that we live in a
democracy so even if you call them like
what do you mean I'm just trying to help
I think it's even one step than that
they I know what you mean and you could
think that about me but but I know I'm
doing the right thing but I know I'm
doing the right thing and so I'm going
to do it anyway and see that's what the
American Revolution was F for we got to
stop using the word deep State I agree I
agree I call it the permanent State
Shadow government but I call it the
managerial class because it's not it
starts to sound so conspiratorial I
really think and it's not even about
conspiratorial it's really about this
idea that there are these people with
nefarious intent and when we remove
ourselves exactly individual and
nefarious action it's something it's
it's a systematic phenomenon because you
force a person who believes they're
doing good right will noten believe the
means are Justified not talking about me
can't be talking about me I'm doing good
for my people I'm do I'm doing what's
right and that's what you have to
understand is these people believe that
they're doing what's right for Humanity
and for most of human history now you
take now now I say the American
Revolution was fought for now you take a
historical view for most of human
history make American Revolution point
because I'm still a little come to I'm
bringing that in here pre-american
Revolution for most of human history The
View was okay the idea that you get to
speak your mind openly as long as I get
to in return or the idea that we the
people cause a government to come into
existence that's accountable to us M
where every one of us has a voice and
vote that counts equally in like this
weird Democratic process where we count
up votes and decide who's in charge and
you get to vote them
out that's nutty right these what the
people would demand would cause Humanity
itself to cease to exist that's how
stupid people are is the kinds of
decisions they would make the American
Revolution was fought on the 1776 was
based on one idea which is that for
better or worse
we the people still decide who governs
so it wasn't just an American Revolution
it was a revolution of thought it was a
it was it fundamentally a revolution of
thought absolutely which echoed a little
bit and mutated a little bit to get to
the French Revolution in 1789 but let's
just talk about the American Revolution
was I think I think the OG version of
this and and the intellectual
predecessors of it were like John lock
it started in Europe but our founding
fathers they weren't the most I mean
they were brilliant people but they
weren't The Originators but they were
the implementers of a vision of
Enlightenment thought that caused the
United States to come into existence
they had a juvenile enough system that
they could Implement these ideas that's
right that's right and and so that's
what the American Revolution was fought
for and so then we have to accept that
we're the weird ones actually we as in
America because for most human history
in most countries in many across the
world today those that haven't followed
America's example that's how it's done
and so what you're seeing right now
isn't this devious new Sinister
conspiracy to the norm it's just a
revert to the norm it's exactly what it
is it's just a it's just the natural
historical tendency we live in this
right now this just reverting to the
norm of all of human history I saw you
talking at uh when when you were
stumping for for Trump in New Hampshire
and you likened it to the American
Revolution and I IR rolled because I
didn't understand contextually what you
were talking about that's what I'm
talking about I probably didn't explain
it as no it's not about explaining it's
like you said in these short amounts of
time it's very hard to break down an
idea this sophisticated like think about
it took us 30 minutes to go from the
initiate of the deep State just the idea
for us to understand to how it works in
Corporate America to back to politics
and how humans have been operating in
this way because it's constant it's is
it and weirdly like there's like a
biological impulse for it probably yeah
we're not there's almost societal
impulse part of it's native hardw part
of it's just the nature of human nature
and how we relate to each other and and
and this thing about the old worldview
that Humanity would cease to exist
that's literally what much of the
managerial class beliefs today as it
relates to climate change I mean for
example you could pick your favorite one
Co that if we really left it to
self-governance and we were serious
about that you pick your favorite fill
in- the blank the planet would cease to
exist so it has to be a small group of
enlightened members of the managerial
class that do what's right's an not just
because and not just because they want
to enrich themselves in their pocketbook
now here's the distin to draw too stupid
the Nicki Haley of the world are in it
for their pocketbook but remember we
said they're not the managerial class
they're the pawns for
seen maneral Class Cuts them in because
those are operators but what they really
the real people who are the real
managerial class hardcore are actually
doing it out of a sense of benevolence
there's there's a uh and I I don't want
to completely discredit this entire
conversation because I think it's great
by comparing it to burning man but I do
have a point about burning man have you
ever ever gone I've always wanted to but
we've never made it actually one of the
one of the T is this radical
self-reliance there's nobody really
watching but there's no one really
watching you right there's nobody
watching you build there's no like
Constructor like a do people going oh is
this is how many nails did you put into
this is this going to fit is everything
going to work out right there's no uh
traffic cop that's just waiting to make
sure you stop at a stop sign or anything
like that everybody's relying on
theirself and when you're relying on
yourself you want to build something you
can walk on you want to build something
you can jump on you want to make sure
you stop because there might be a car
it's about to run in front of you there
is a kind of neutering of people when
you have Daddy or Mommy around all the
time making sure you don't do anything
bad and it speaks to what you just said
this idea of if you leave us to our own
devices and I understand Bernie man is
super privileged and people have a lot
of money and time whatever but it is
people being left to their own devices
to take care of thems and they're
accountable if anything goes wrong with
yours and when you're accountable if
anything goes wrong nobody's going to
come pick you up necessarily you're
going to make sure you know what maybe
I'm not going to build this with too few
screws maybe I'm not going to find a way
to cheat myself out of this situation
because I could hurt myself and I could
hurt the people around me so I think it
does speak to what you're talking about
which is this like
self-reliance has been almost stripped
and it's been Stripped by an arrogance
yes and arrogance of they're too dumb to
build the thing correctly right now
there is another side of that which is
these people are going to build
something for someone else and if we
don't regulate the way they build it
they'll build it in the cheapest way and
take advantage of those innocent people
that also exists like as much as unions
are a pain in the ass they were created
for a reason mhm
they came into existence for a reason
the created implies that so this you're
going have a separate discussion about
unions I actually have very different
attitude towards private sector unions
than I do the public sector no public
sector if you're negotiating against the
government it's very peculiar people and
also the people but think about it like
you're negotiating against somebody
who's out of office in two or three
years right so of course if I'm mayor
and I want to get the teachers union on
my side and be like well listen I'm out
of here to be governor in a few years
yeah give them whatever deal they want
if I'm negotiating against my boss who I
have to work for or he has to hire me
and all of my the other workers that are
part of this company this is a 10year
relationship a 20- year relationship a
30e relationship I'm going to make sure
we hammer out a deal that's beneficial
for the both of us but I feel too often
what happens with people in politics is
yeah just give them whatever they want
who cares what the [__] happens to the
state I'm out in four years because I'm
going to do something else and that's
why negotiating against public sector is
different than the private sector I
agree also guys don't forget about prize
picks hurry up and sign up NFL playoffs
is the best time of the year this is
what you got to do I'm giving you my
sing locks first of all this is a four
player thing so it's a four-player pick
so if you hit you can make you can make
some cash off of prize picks first of
all Isaiah Pacho will get more than 63
and a half rushing yards Patrick Mahomes
will get more than 248 a half passing
yards Travis Kelce I love you I love
what you're doing with Taylor Swift but
I think you're going to get less than 65
receiving yards and Lamar Jackson MVP I
think you're going to get more than 212
passing yards and sign up for priz
pick.com use that promo code Schultz
they will match your initial deposit up
to $100 so you put in 100 you 100 for
free